we talked about it a little bit last
time you were in here but you said you
didn't finish school so you didn't get
all of this success from necessarily a
traditional education what advice would
you give to your kids or other people
that wanted to be successful successful
i mean to me it's like what i instill is
that i'm trying to instill the joy of
learning in my children and that that
life's greatest gift is that you get to
learn evolve and and grow and so even i
taught them how to fix the toilet
you know and he was like i can't i can't
fix i don't know how he was all scared
and then like finally showed him until
he finally could figure out how he could
do it himself and when he did it himself
he's like oh yes you know and and i'm
like you see that a card because i need
do you have a car card oh your toilet's
messed up yeah his little hands could go
to work for you quicker
but i it's just how do you
just learn how do you learn to love
learning and look at it more from you
can do anything in this life
if you choose to learn it and grow and
grow into it and everything's hard at
first until you make it easy right and
so
to me i'm living proof of like
the world that i've created and what
i've grown into that you can become
anything if you put in the effort to
learn it i see you you showed us the
picture before you have sisters is that
one one sister one sister and your
parents are they they gotta be blown
away now like i know you you said
it's funny that your mom said why do you
have to say you didn't finish school and
aren't you embarrassed about that but
they got to look at you and go oh my god
yeah this is yeah it's funny because
it's like you know
since i you know my mom sent me a text
message about what you know i'm so
thankful that you know i'm really proud
you know like from being there this
weekend with them because i try to
include them in everything that we do
they're still in ohio yeah
so it's like um you know it's just
important for for me to continue to have
those those experiences and they are i
just think it's it's beyond a level
because you gotta understand even when
you know probably 10 years ago i started
i paid um
for my parents to retire you know and
even then i had to pay one bit of money
to down the center to pay for all the
bills and then give them separate money
but they're not together i know they're
together but that's how like they didn't
want to like they i had to do it
separately so that like my mom wouldn't
complain that i'm going to keep working
then your dad needs to keep working and
i'm like he doesn't want to work he
wants to golf you know so i had to
negotiate with them but wait wait wait
wait how old are your parents
uh dad's 82
mom's 78. what business was your dad in
he sold
suits
suit salesman a suit salesman did your
mom work she worked uh as like a
um like a secretary in like a doctor's
office so when you say i want you to
retire how much money do you give
somebody to retire well i bought them a
house gave them 200 g's and then paid
for like their l and then just pay for
their lives you know then my the same
with my sister i bought him a house your
sister married yeah and then just pay
for you know pay for their lives you
know
she retired
no she she does real estate on the side
but i don't want i don't want my
immediate family i don't want them to
ever think about money ever you know and
anytime
you know my sister will complain about
something i'll just you know send her 50
g's and be like you know build a pool
whatever my feet hurt he's going to
complain
you know because i mean think about it
immediate family if you if you had an
amazing brother yeah he would take care
of those feet yeah you know but but at
the same time i just look at you you
know brother owes me nine bucks what
about your wife's family
you know i i i
would
do any and and i i i have actually you
know done some side side giving to some
people in her family but i i i let it
run through her on what she's willing to
do because sometimes that can cause more
friction than help yeah and so i don't
again i would never
i don't you know the way that our
relationship is is is just you know
deeply like wide open and we are we have
incredible communication and talk deeply
about everything so it's like you know
it's at i would do anything at any time
for any anyone that she would want
[Music]